so here's a tip before we get into
chapter 1 pack an extra pair of pants
trust me I wish I did you'll thank me
later here's everything you need to know
before you go
[Music]
let's talk about penny was I know I have
our template of space to Stephen King
the iconic storyteller first introduced
us to penny wise with his novel
published in 1986 in the novel the story
alternates between two time periods but
the film's executes the timeline with a
clean break the main characters are just
kids in the 80s in chapter 1 chapter 2
is where we catch up with them as adults
the story was also turned into a
miniseries that aired in 1990 starring
Tim Curry as penny wise okay let's get
into the film series set in Derry Maine
in 1988 chapter one kicks off with one
of the main characters Bill and his
younger brother Georgie
one day after making a paper sailboat
together Georgie takes it outside to
play while Bill is sick in bed this is
where we're introduced to penny wise the
dancing clown so he calls himself he
tells Georgie who wouldn't believe that
the young kid tries to get a sailboat
back but the clown reveals his true
colors
time passes school is letting out and
summer is under way members Ben and Mike
are the next two to see penny wise they
each experienced him in very different
ways
bill is still haunted by the
disappearance of his younger brother and
discovers that his body might have ended
up in the Barrens a marshy wasteland
connected by the sewers while searching
for georgie bill and his friends Ritchie
Eddie and Stan run into Ben who is being
tortured by a gang of bullies Ben
escapes from the bullies and runs into
Bill and his friends in the Barrens
don't tell me that don't you look
it's Betty rivers in the meantime one of
the bullies is attacked by penny wise in
the form of a horde of zombies bill and
the other boys take Ben to the pharmacy
to help him there they meet and befriend
Beverly Ben's crush kiddo sign looks
like someone killed him when they all
returned home each of them are
terrorized by penny wise in different
forms after their horrific experiences
the group of kids bond and refer to
themselves as the losers Club they also
realize they're being haunted by the
same creature that same group of bullies
is back again with a new victim Mike but
this time the losers Club chases them
away with rocks
[Music]
weeks later the new band of friends gets
together at Bill's house they have a
theory everywhere it happens it's it's
all connected by the sewers and they all
meet up at the wall house as they're
using an old projector he comes after
them but fails the crew goes to the
house and Pennywise
it as the kids refer to him separates
them from one another using his
shape-shifting ways the kids have to
fight him off in various horrifying
scenarios before escaping down into a
well in the mansion it slashes Ben the
group disbanded after being so shaken
from fear of the clown
leaving only bill and Beverley to fight
some time later Pennywise returns Henry
who we thought was dead Henry is now
losing his mind and kills his father
before pursuing the losers Club for
Pennywise Beverly is kidnapped by
Pennywise after fighting off her abusive
father Henry arrives at the house soon
after and goes for Mike first but he
meets his demise quickly they find
Beverly and a canna tonic state floating
in mid-air along with the bodies of the
other missing children in hopes of
saving her Ben kisses Beverley Pennywise
tries to fool bill into thinking he's
Georgie but he doesn't fall for it but
you're not Georgie
during its attempt to kidnap bill the
group joins together to battle against
the clown after they beat him Pennywise
descends back into the well and the
floating children come back down to the
ground
Bill's friends comfort him because well
it's obvious he's had a rough time
one month later Beverley has a dream
that Pennywise will return in 27 years
so the group swears in a blood oath that
they'll return to Derry as adults to
kill him for good if he pops back up at
the very end Bill kisses Beverley whoa
let's see how this love triangle pans
out in Chapter two what are you hoping
to see in Chapter two it looks like the
movie will tell us more about the origin
of Pennywise and who the kids have
become 27 years later they've enlisted
some great stars to play the grown-up
members of the losers Club Jessica
Chastain James McAvoy Bill Hader
Isaiah Mustafa James Ransone and Jay
Ryan and Bill skarsgård has reprised the
role of penny wise well folk down here
yes we do wait have they forgotten what
they went through it looks like Mike
will have to refresh their memories me
and I've left
I remember all of it well I know I can't
wait to see this new chapter so now you
know and now you can go see it chapter 2
on September 6th